pour relier les dossiers des patients entre les hôpitaux.
Les ID sont imprimées sous forme de codes barres
sur des étiquettes, collées sur les livrets de santé
conservés par chaque patient.
Grâce à cet identifiant à codes barres,
un simple scan avec un lecteur de codes barres
retrouve rapidement les dossiers du patient.
Pas besoin de réécrire leurs données personnelles
sur des registres papier à chaque visite.
Soudain, les files d'attente se sont raccourcies.
Ainsi, les patients comme les mères portant des bébés sur leur dos,
ont pu attendre moins longtemps avant la consultation.
Et s'ils perdent leurs livrets de santé,
leurs données peuvent même être retrouvées en utilisant leur nom.
La façon dont on prononce et on épèle les noms est très variable.
On mélange facilement les R, les L et
les versions anglaises et vernaculaires des noms des patients.
Même avec Soundex,
une méthode de référence pour grouper les mots selon leur ressemblance sonore,
ce n'était pas assez précis.
On a donc dû le modifier
pour nous aider à relier et faire concorder les enregistrements existants.
Avant l'iPhone,
les ingénieurs en logiciels développaient pour les PC.
Mais par expérience,
on savait que notre système électrique n'était pas assez fiable
pour des PC.
On a donc reprogrammé des terminaux de points de vente à écran tactile,
destinés aux commerces,
en postes de travail hospitaliers.
À l'époque, on importait des terminaux internet appelés i-Openers
qui avaient été fabriqués au moment de la bulle Internet
par une entreprise américaine en faillite.
On a modifié leur écran
pour intégrer des capteurs tactiles
et l'électricité provient de batteries.
Quand on a commencé, on n'a pas trouvé de réseau fiable pour envoyer les données,
surtout depuis les hôpitaux à la campagne.
On a donc construit nos propres antennes.
On a créé un réseau sans fil
et on a relié des hôpitaux de Lilongwe,
la capitale du Malawi.
(Applaudissements)
travaillant au sein d'un campus hospitalier,
on a observé le personnel de santé utiliser le système
et construire petit à petit un système d'information,
qui gère maintenant l'archivage des dossiers du Sida
dans tous les grands hôpitaux publics du Malawi.
Chacun de ces hôpitaux accueille plus de 2 000 séropositifs.
Désormais, les travailleurs de santé, qui passaient des jours
sur les chiffres des rapports trimestriels,
produisent les mêmes rapports en un rien de temps.
Des experts du secteur de la santé du monde entier
viennent au Malawi pour apprendre comment nous l'avons fait.
(Applaudissements)
C'est inspirant et divertissant
de suivre les tendances technologiques globales.
Mais, pour qu'elles fonctionnent,
dans des environnements avec peu de ressources,
comme les hôpitaux publics en Afrique subsaharienne,
on a été obligés de devenir multifonctions
et de construire des systèmes complets, sans oublier l'infrastructure,
à partir de rien.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)